mathieu legault s'est aperçu que quelque
chose clochait de la semaine dernière
quand son téléphone soudainement cessé
de se connecter au réseau cellulaire
il a rapidement compris qu'il était
victime d'un voleur d'identité qui a
usurpé son numéro la personne n'achete
un téléphone prépayées et a demandé le
transfert de ce numéro de téléphone de
mon opérateur fido chez bell le fraudeur
en question connaissait
vraisemblablement son numéro de
téléphone et son adresse courriel
avec ces deux informations il a réussi à
prendre le contrôle du compte paypal de
monsieur legault pour se connecter
le voleur a probablement entrer
l'adresse courriel de mathieu et indiqué
qu'il avait oublié le mot de passe
on m'envoie un scrupule il ensuite reçu
un code de sécurité par texto lui
permettant d'entrer dans le compte
paypal et voile et à l'intérieur de mon
compte ils ont changé le mot de passe le
fraudeur a ensuite acheté pour 1700
dollars de marchandises avec son compte
paypal en donnant deux adresses de
livraison dans l'est de montréal
la personne et russell fabrice la fin
des transactions chez deux commerçait
racheter du matériel informatique des
playstation entre autres jeux vidéo est
l'un de nos transactions c'était des
valises heureusement matu legault a pu
faire annuler ces achats effectués en
son nom ce stratagème n'aurait pas pu
fonctionner si sa ligne téléphonique
n'avait pas été transféré à son insu je
trouve pas ça normal ou encore
aujourd'hui qu'une personne soit capable
de prendre possession d'un numéro de
téléphone avec la facilité avec laquelle
la personne qui attend même ford et le
feu la concurrence force cette
complaisance est ce que tout le monde
puisse avoir accès au produit le plus
rapidement possible donc si on veut y
réduire ces fraudes là il doit y avoir
davantage de vérifications systématiques
de la part des commerçants
mathieu legault a été victime du vol de
données chez desjardins
mais impossible de savoir si c'est la
cause de ces mésaventures il a porté
plainte à la police
ici olivier bachar radio canada montréal